all right so maybe we should get ready
to get started so hi everyone welcome
for to the last day of the latus
workshop and a natural transition to the
quantum workshop that's going to take
place next week today we're actually
going to talk about applications for of
lattice cryptographic techniques in the
quantum regime and the first talk of the
morning or whatever other hour you're at
is by really Mahadev who is going to
tell us about a quantum version for
fully homomorphic encryption
please Amira oh let me just remind the
protocol for asking questions so if
you're a panel is then you can just
unmute yourself and ask a question
politely please and as attendees you
have access to the Q&A to the Q&A
sidebar and you can ask type your
questions there either
or mila is going to see the questions
herself or I'll try to keep an eye out
me and the other panelists will try to
keep an eye out either sort of address
the question or refer to her Mila all
right come along please
Vika so like Zika said my talk is on
classical homomorphic encryption for
quantum circuits this is in both quantum
computing and cryptography and I try to
keep the quantum computing parts pretty
easy to follow hopefully but I encourage
a lot of questions as I don't have that
much content I and I did that to create
room for questions so you should feel
free to ask questions during the talk
and after so I'll get started and to
start I'll start with the topic that
should be familiar to most of you in
this audience which is classical
homomorphic encryption so in classical
homomorphic encryption you have a weak
client and a much more powerful server
and the goal of the client is to
privately delegate a computation to the
more powerful server so he wants to
encrypt some input data m and then the
server should be able to compute a
classical circuit on top of the
encrypted data so the server never
learns anything about the data while
he's computing
yeah so the server never learned
anything about the data while he's
computing and this was first shown to be
possible by Craig Gentry in 2008 and in
my talk the setting is going to be
similar but now the server will be a
quantum machine and when I say a week
clients the client is a classical
machine so that's why the client is much
weaker than the server in this setting
and now the question is the same can
this week classical client use the
computing power of a quantum device
while maintaining privacy so ideally
what this classical client should be
able to do is send over some classically
encrypted data to the server and then
the server should be able to compute a
unitary on top of the data so he instead
of applying a classical circuit home
morphic li now he wants to apply a
general quantum circuit which we
represent as a unitary quantum operator
so he can I don't know if there are
questions
so far you're okay are you okay yeah so
the goal of the server is now to compute
a unitary transformation on top of the
classically encrypted data and the first
question here is whether we can just
immediately use classical homomorphic
encryption schemes for this purpose so
can the client just classically encrypt
his data send it over to the server and
then can the server apply a quantum
circuit on top of classically encrypted
data and it turns out that there is a
property of classical homomorphic
encryption schemes which makes this
quite difficult and that property is
that classical homomorphic encryption
schemes are inherently probabilistic
there are many different encryptions of
a single bit and that's necessary
because in classical homomorphic
encryption schemes the server is
computing on top of encrypted data so if
the encryptions word is deterministic
let's say there was a single encryption
for a bit zero then the server could
always figure out what's going on by
maybe applying different computations
and seeing where the different
computations end up he could compare the
output ciphertext so this is an inherent
property of classical homomorphic
encryption schemes but it seems to
conflict with the quantum property of
interference so now let me
tell you what this quantum property is
and to tell you what the quantum
property of interference is I first need
to tell you what the Hadamard transform
is this is a key operator in quantum
computation and all the Hadamard
transform is its the quantum Fourier
transform so it's a reflection about PI
by 8 and this picture shows you the
reflection and on the bottom you can see
what what it does to quantum states so
it Maps a 0 qubit to uniform
superposition over 0 & 1 and it maps a
one qubit to a uniform superposition
over 0 & 1 as well but now there's a
phase of negative 1 now that I've
introduced the hat on our transform I
can tell you what interference means so
interference says that elements of a
superposition representing the same bit
string but with opposite amplitudes must
cancel and you can see this with the
Hadamard transform so if I take the
Hadamard transform and apply it to a
uniform superposition over 0 & 1 I
should get 0 another way of seeing this
is we can break this down it's a linear
operator and if you apply it to 0 first
you get 0 plus 1 and if you apply it to
1 you get 0 minus 1 and what happens is
that the two ones are cancelling out so
that's what I mean by interference these
two elements of the superposition which
are representing the same bit string but
with opposite amplitudes must cancel now
if we try to use homomorphic encryption
in the most naive way let's say what we
do is we just replace these bits with
classically encrypted bits so replace 0
with the encryption of 0 replace one
with the encryption of 1 now this is
exactly where the issue of having many
different encryptions for a single bit
really messes up whatever quantum
computation we're trying to do because
now let's say the two encryptions of 1
were different they might not cancel
there's no reason that I should think
they cancel so now if I just look at
this naively I should not get encryption
of 0 out which is what I need and this
is why the the probabilistic nature of
homomorphic encryption seems to come in
conflict with properties that we need in
quantum computing and so far
I've done is I just told you the old
Miller yeah this is Vinod if you if you
instead think of the encryption of one
as being not a an encryption of one but
there but the superposition overall
interruptions of one then this would
cancel well what do you mean all
encryptions of one because noises are
changing right like what if if you have
a superposition and then the noise
distribution changes as you apply
operations so you have to say that that
superposition remains constant
throughout the computation I see this is
specific to lwe but if you Jen if you
think generically of you know of
encryption schemes I am saying you know
superposition over all randomness you
know it ping all round we call possible
encryptions of one yeah which is
actually well defined for lwe I see what
you're saying what if you could then
then then this this particular problem
would by doing we need but I'm not quite
sure what would happen with home illicit
computation right I have a follow-up
question so if we were to do this super
super position then the scheme is no
longer encrypted classically I mean we
no longer encrypting classically right
I can't adhere we really wanted to do
classical encryption well compute I
think we know they're just suggesting so
here I suggested one way of using
classical encryption for quantum
computations and we know they're
suggesting a different way of using
classical homomorphic encryption for
quantum computation so how would you
prepare that superposition that you
would need there that would be tricky
even oh yeah but yeah I don't want to
assert about yeah sure yeah I just
something okay yeah okay so like I mean
I've just said this is just one way of
using classical home morphic encryption
schemes for quantum computing and there
are many other ways so this way seems to
run into an inherent obstacle but there
is one other way which seems much more
natural in the quantum setting and I'm
gonna focus on that method
this talk and it's called the quantum
one-time pad so the quantum one-time pad
is just the classical analog of the
one-time pad and I'll first tell you
what this encryption looks like it's an
information theoretic encryption then
I'll convert it to the computational
setting and show how it can be used in
the setting of quantum homomorphic
encryption and again this this one-time
pad encryption is just it uses classical
homomorphic encryption in a different
way to encrypt quantum states so here's
the information theoretic method of
encryption question
okay here is an information theoretic
method of encryption we're starting with
a single qubit state sign and we like to
encrypt it and it goes in steps the
first step is to sample a bit Z at
random and apply the poly phase operator
to the state so what this operator does
is if Z equals one it inserts a phase of
negative one and if Z equals zero it
doesn't do anything to the state the
next step is called the poly bit slip
operator and it's the same as a
classical one-time pad so here a bit X
is sampled at random and now the qubits
are flipped in superposition based on
the bit X so if X is equal to one each
bit is slipped and if X is equal to zero
nothing happens now when you combine X
and Z this is called the poly one-time
pad and it information theoretically
hides the single qubit state so if you
choose X and Z at random apply the poly
operators to the state all information
from about the state is gone this is an
information theoretic one-time pad but
just like in the classical world you can
take an information theoretic one-time
pad and convert it into a computational
encryption by including the classically
encrypted one-time pad keys so this is
exactly what's done here now we have a
two-part encryption the first part is
the one-time padded quantum state and
the second part is the classically
encrypted one-time pad keys now this is
a computational encryption of a quantum
state which uses classical homomorphic
encryption because to encrypt these keys
I will use a classical homomorphic
encryption scheme
ah yeah this is rich oh yeah I just
wanna ask a question maybe also helps
other content dummies in the meeting
when you say that the informations there
I think a high the state isin presumably
which one a high this alpha 0 alpha 1
you might bring a little bit more you
which then say the height alphas you
have two one alpha one sure
okay so let's first go to a very simple
case where this state is essentially
classical so let's say alpha 0 equals 1
and alpha 1 equals 0 so this is just a 0
qubit now you can see that just this
second step information theoretically
hides the state because it's either 0 or
1 with equal probability
so that's officially and now the second
step that was just for classical States
and what that first step does is a phase
operator it kind of hides the properties
of the superposition so now imagine that
you had a zero plus one state what the
phase operator does is it either maps it
to zero plus one or zero minus one but
these are orthogonal states so now he
has no idea which of these two states
season and so that completely hides the
phase information which is essentially
the information about the superposition
okay thank you yeah no problem actually
think that this is maybe a good point
for for other questions if other people
or the panelists or entity attendees
have additional questions because we I
guess stepped into the technical quantum
regime and I'm assuming that people
might want to ask yeah so just a
clarification question this is shafy so
you still have the information theoretic
encryption in addition you're encrypting
the choices that were made the random
choices that were made here so at this
point there's no benefit in this thing
right you've added information right
this is unnecessary for okay good work
what would have been the in the up and
the above thing the one-time pad is Z
and X hmm so you're essentially
encrypting the pad is that right yes
good I mean there's a okay
it's not useful right now but it'll be
useful for the homomorphic Park which
I'll get into in the next slide so you
yeah just once so you encrypting using
key and then you're also sending along
an encryption of the key yes okay so
I'll continue to the next slide so far
what I've done is I just told you how to
computationally encrypt the state and
now I need to link this to homomorphic
encryption and say how the server can
apply operations on the state so what's
happening right now is that the
classical client just has some data and
he first encrypts it and sends it over
to the quantum server so in this picture
it might be a little confusing because I
keep saying classical client but in this
picture it looks like the classical
client is sending over classical keys as
well as a quantum one-time padded state
and the thing to observe here is that
actually if this one time if the state
sign is a standard is a classical string
then the one time padded quantum state
is just the one time pad of classical
string so this this thing that looks
like a quantum state is actually just a
classical string so in the case that the
input data is classical the one time
padded quantum state is also possible so
the client can be entirely classical in
that case but for full generality I'm
just going to cover the case where the
client wants to send over an arbitrary
one time padded quantum state and the
server should be able to apply a general
quantum operation on this state so how
does that look how does the server apply
a general quantum operation to this one
time padded state it turns out that for
most quantum gates what the server can
do is split his computation into a
classical computation on the one-time
pad keys and a quantum and a parallel
quantum computation on the one time
padded State so this is what happens for
most of the quantum gates see quantum
server applies a quantum operation to
the one time padded state because of
this quantum operation the one-time pad
keys will change to account for this
change the server apply
a classical homomorphic encryption to
the one-time padded keys to update his
keys according to which cake he applied
so so far it's pretty straightforward
but there is one complication there is
one gate which is required for a
universal set of quantum gates for which
the server can't just slip the
computation into these parallel
classical and quantum computations for
this gate what the server has to do is
take one of his classically encrypted
keys and convert it into a quantum
operation so he has to take a
classically encrypted bit and based on
that bit he has to conditionally apply a
quantum operation to his one time padded
state and this is the key difficulty in
quantum homomorphic encryption schemes
how do you take a classically encrypted
bit and convert it into a quantum
operation and this is it's at some point
you're going to tell us a bit more about
the quantum computation model about
gates and Universal gates and so on no
no we don't need to know you don't need
to know there's gonna be one gate that
you need to know about called the C
naught gate and I'll get into that on
the next slide but all I'm going to say
about quantum homomorphic computation is
that it boils down into these parallel
classical and quantum computations and
the hard part is connecting the two
doing a classically doing a quantum gate
controlled on the classically encrypted
bit okay so at this point this is a good
time to tell you a little bit about
previous work so so far the set up that
I've told you with the one-time pad keys
converting them into computational
encryptions and then running the
computation in parallel this was all
known in previous work and in all of the
previous work they knew that the key
difficulty with this conversion of a
classical ciphertext into a quantum
operation and to take care of that
difficulty they required quantum states
so the client had to send over quantum
states to the server and this quantum
state had some secret information
encoded into it which allowed the server
to do this conversion to take one of his
classical cipher texts and apply a
quantum operation based on now the
teams were very interesting and they led
to a lot of advances in the field of
delegated quantum computing but there
was a key difficulty and the difficulty
is as follows if the client is sending
over quantum states to assist the server
in the computation these quantum states
cannot be reused so each time the client
wants to delegate a quantum computation
he has to send over this set of quantum
states moreover the number of quantum
states corresponding to the size of the
quantum circuit being delegated so if
you put that together what it's saying
is that with these schemes with the
quantum client the quantum client had to
run a quantum computation of the same
size as a quantum sir
so this was the key obstacle and that's
why using a classical client is very
different because you don't have these
issues with the quantum state all the
server has to do is use his classical
information to do this conversion from a
classical ciphertext to a quantum
operation now the next thing so like I
said says Vica I'm not going to talk any
more about the first bullet point the
rest of this talk will focus on the
second bullet point how to convert a
classical cipher text into a quantum
operation so now is a good time to ask
questions if you want to clarify the
bigger picture before I get more into
that second bullet points yes let's take
a second for everybody to sort of see if
they're up to speed I want to ask the
question
right looks like they want you to go on
delayed question so so I just to
understand what what do you what you are
looking for here you know if you have a
qubit alpha 0 plus beta 1 right you want
alpha 0 so this is sort of following up
on what Peter said on the comments alpha
0 plus beta times a unitary applied to 1
something like that that's what you want
if the bit is 0 you do nothing if the
bit is 1 you apply unitary and if
another super position you want to do
this so now you only have been encrypted
bet and you can't possibly do this
because that would reveal information
about that would violate semantic
security so instead what you're hoping
to get is an encryption of that qubit
under you know okay and if anyone didn't
follow I'm gonna cover exactly what
minute is just said next yeah okay so
now let me go into this conversion this
conversion from a classical ciphertext
into a quantum operation and the first
thing I need to do is tell you what that
quantum operation is and then what it
looks like to convert a classical
ciphertext into that quantum operation
so this quantum operation is called the
C naught gate and all the C naught gate
is it's a quantum version of the XOR
gate so it's a reversible XOR gate and
that's what this picture depicts so you
have two wires they're bits a and B the
first wire remains unchanged and in the
second wire where X oaring the first bit
into the same and in this picture it
looks like you just have bits but in
general these bits will be in
superposition now what the quantum
server has to do during the homomorphic
computation is he has to apply a C not
conditioned on an encrypted bit so he'll
get as input some encrypted bit s and he
should either apply the C not or not
based on us if s is equal to 0 do
nothing if s is equal to 1 apply the C
not key
and here's what this looks like in terms
of a circuit diagram so now there's one
more wire which is the classical
encryption of a bit s and now if you
look at that third wire what's happening
is that a is ex-ored into that register
only if s is equal to 1 and if s is
equal to 0 nothing and in this third
line I just wanted to write the state in
superposition and show you what the
output should be in superposition so in
general the server should be able to
take as input an arbitrary two qubit
quantum state a classically encrypted
bit s and output the result of
conditionally applying the si not gate
to his input quantum states
so this operation is quite strange
because what the server is doing is he
has this classically encrypted bit s
which he can't understand so it's hidden
from him but somehow he is applying a
quantum operation based on a bit that he
cannot see so that's why this is really
the crux of quantum homomorphic
encryption because it's quite difficult
to take a hidden classical bit and
convert it into a quantum operation and
like Vinod said as I've written it here
this is impossible because if the server
can do this conversion if you can just
compute this quantum state for an
arbitrary two qubit quantum state he can
set let's say a equals to 1 B equals to
zero and he can learn the bit s so the
detail that I skipped over was that this
output state so when the server is
applying this operation the output of a
plan find the conditional C naught has
to be encrypted and it's going to be
encrypted with the one-time pad that I
just showed you so this entire operation
of converting a classical cipher text to
a quantum operation to the quantum C
naught operation is called the encrypted
C naught operation and now now that I've
told you what this operation is let me
just summarize what I've told you about
quantum Hall effect encryption so far so
I told you that the encryption scheme
that we'll be using is the computational
version of the poly one-time pad which
consists of sending over classically
encrypted keys as well as a one-time
padded quantum state then I told you
that the homomorphic computation mostly
boils down to parallel classical and
quantum computations where the server is
applying quantum operations to his state
and then updating the one-time pad keys
classically as he goes along using a
classical homomorphic computation
however there was one key difficulty
which is when the server has to apply a
quantum operation which is dependent on
the classically encrypted keys and I
call this operation the encrypted C not
operation and here's what it looks like
the server takes as input the encryption
of a bit s an arbitrary two qubit
quantum state and he applies the C not
conditionally to the two qubit quantum
state any
puts the encrypted value of the output
so this encryption matches this first
picture where he's outputting
classically encrypted keys and a quantum
one-time pad at state
and so this was a suitable encryption
that I referred to earlier the state is
not in the clear it's encrypted by the
computational power a one-time pad now
now I'm gonna continue to building the
encrypted C not operation and once I
build the encrypted C not operation then
I will eventually link back to classical
homomorphic encryption schemes so what
I'll say is that certain classical
homomorphic encryption schemes allow
this conversion from a classically
encrypted cipher text into a quantum
operation and therefore those schemes
can be used to homomorphic Li evaluate
quantum sir so that's the final result
the final result is that there are
classical homomorphic encryption schemes
which satisfies certain requirements
which enable them to be used for
homomorphic evaluation of quantum sir
and that's what I'll go into next into
building the encrypted C naught
operation and before I continue are
there any questions so far
another question you know if you look at
the distribution of X and Z that come
out of this operation right will they be
unity uniformly random pair of bits
what great like information theoretical
uniform well yes if the server is honest
sure I mean it's not it's not critical I
was just curious
quantum transformation should be
reversible so from from your picture it
looks like s kind of is only
participated in C naught but the
information about tests could be lost
and some who you know it's not the cause
as quantum transformation should be
reversible and it is lost
well first of all so S can't be lost
because it's classically encrypted data
so this doesn't disappear no but you can
really try to you start with encryption
of s now you have encryption of XZ X and
Z independent of else so on the right
hand side the only dependence on us is
she not as and it wasn't clear for me
that this information theoretical editor
since it does information theoretically
determine s okay if you have the
encryption of X Z you can decrypt them
and then decrypt the state and then find
C not s but I'm I don't think I'm
getting your question because
information yeah I just thought that
don't you get a plus B s and a plus B s
would C be 0 for example information
about s is lost but encryption of s is
classical so I could copy it on the side
and okay so this this means the case
just like in complete picture so this
thing doesn't disappear okay I just
wanted to make sure yeah okay
any more questions before I continue
okay so now I'm gonna get into the
encrypted C not operation and how to
build it and in order to tell you how to
build the encrypted C not operation I
need to tell you about a primitive
called trapdoor coffre functions because
these will be the main building block
for the encrypted CMOS operation so let
me start by defining trapdoor quarry
functions these are introduced by
goldwasser Macaulay under vest in 1984
and a trapdoor claw free function pair
is a pair of functions F 0 and F 1 which
are injective and they have the same
image and then the hardness property is
that it is computationally difficult for
either a quantum or a classical machine
to find a claw which is a pair of pre
images which map to the same point and
then the trapdoor property says that if
there is a trapdoor so if an algorithm
has access to a trapdoor then there is
an efficient algorithm for inversion so
given the trapdoor in an image why this
algorithm can output the two pre images
of Y now if you put those two conditions
together what I'm saying is without the
trapdoor both quantum and classical
machines cannot find even a single pair
of pre images which map to the sample
that's the claw free property but with a
trapdoor it's very easy to take an image
Y and invert it to find the two pre
images which could have mapped to that
image way now this
these tractor claw free functions are
pretty interesting in the quantum
setting because quantum machines have a
unique capability what a quantum machine
can do a sample a random image why and
create a uniform superposition over the
corresponding cloth so over the two pre
images corresponding to Y I'll tell you
in a second how exactly the quantum
machine does this but for now I just
wanted to talk a little bit more about
this superposition so the superposition
is interesting because it seems like it
contains information about both pre
images but I just said that even for a
quantum machine it's hard to find both
pre images it's hard to find x0 and x1
so how can it be that it's hard to find
the pre images but it's easy to create a
super position over the pre images and
the main thing to note here is that just
creating a super position over the pre
images is not the same as finding it in
order to extract any information from
the super position the quantum machine
has to measure the super position so he
can measure it in many ways one thing he
could do is measure it in something
called the standard basis and in that
case the super position would just
collapse to either 0 axial or 1x 1x
andum and in that case all the quantum
machine has done a sample a random free
image image pair and that's not hard
that's classically reproducible it
doesn't take advantage of the fact that
the quantum machine could create this
interesting state but if the quantum
machine measures it in the Hadamard
basis which is the quantum Fourier
transform that I introduced earlier then
he can obtain some information which is
correlated to both x0 and x1 and this is
the kind of thing that we believe is
hard to do classically and in a joint
paper with Zika Paul Christiano
miss Shaw Johnny and Tomas FIDIC we
introduced this advantage and we showed
that using the superposition the quantum
machine can produce something that a
classical machine cannot reproduce and
then we use this advantage for various
things so we used it to classically test
quantum machines we use it for certified
random to randomness generation and we
use it to classically verify quantum
computation and in this talk I'm not
going to go into any of that
because all I need here for homomorphic
encryption is I need the fact that the
quantum machine can create this uniform
superposition over a random qua so I'm
not gonna say anything more about the
previous work but now I'm just gonna
tell you how the quantum machine creates
this uniform superposition over the PAS
and here's how he doesn't so this is his
goal and what he does is he first
creates a uniform superposition over the
domain of the function so you have a
single bit and then you have a longer
binary string X then the quantum machine
applies the classical function in
superposition so he chooses to either
apply X 0 or F 1 depending on that first
bit B finally what the quantum machine
does is he measures the last register to
obtain an image Y and now the way of
superposition works is if you measure
that last register then the remaining
registers will collapse to only those
values which are consistent with Y so if
it was an injective function for example
then when you measure that last register
Y the preceding the preimage register
would just collapse to one button but
now since we know that there are two pre
images for every image one from F 0 and
F 1 what happens is that when you
measure the last register to obtain an
image Y that pre image register
collapses to a uniform superposition
over the only values which are
consistent with Y which are X 0 and X
and this is just due to the entanglement
in the state and how quantum
superpositions work question yeah so
this might be a silly question but step
one is it efficient yes and the way it's
done is the Fourier transform if you
just take the Fourier transform and
apply it to 0 it maps to 0 plus 1 and if
you apply it to a longer string like 0
like n0 bits then you get a live yeah
sorry I thought that the domain of
you're applying this superposition over
the domain of X I thought and isn't the
domain of X exponential
yes but if the domain the domain size is
exponential but you can think of the
domain as all bit strings of length n
and so all I'm asking oh yeah yeah okay
sorry thanks yeah no okay any more
questions about trap draw free functions
in quantum computing I'm really going to
be relying on this fact that the quantum
machine can create a uniform
superposition over the cloth so it's a
good thing to understand at this point
okay I have one question so you're
saying that you're gonna collapse two to
preimages well so they're preimages so
if we sort of keep going backwards
is there any memory do you see what I'm
saying no so suppose that you had an
iterated squaring here uh-huh
if we take a particular implementation
of claw free permutations oh so I'm
thinking about why is it quadratic
residue say and then I'm taking square
roots and then I want to think about
taking square roots of those square
roots in case they are themselves square
mm-hmm
is there any retaining in any kind of
sense I mean for me this is a little bit
of Voodoo but of the of the let's say
the fourth root I don't quite understand
your question because it so this initial
superposition in line one there is
that's where I'm picking the domain so
if you want to have this nested kind of
thing then don't wouldn't you have to
have a different domain here because I'm
choosing the domain of one function
right but we're in a world where this
dumb that what you're picking the domain
itself actually is a co domain of
another function I know you're picking
in the domain but these X this domain
itself represent something that you know
you could invert on I know can interpret
my quest yeah not sure so so you could
if you think of FB as a simpler function
kind of iterated many times
and B is not a bit anymore it's a
sequence of bits and you know each
iteration where you either pick a one of
the you know the first simple function
or the second simple fassl's imagine
that right and then you can create a
superposition over all the exponentially
many parts you could do the same same
thing really
okay so okay that makes sense and then
when you just measure it the first time
you'll still have many preimages left
and then you keep collapsing it is that
what you're saying I'm saying these
chapter of these chapter permutations
were used there's this one claw actually
there's a lot of strings in it in in
making a function where whether there's
an F 0 and F 1 you think your F sub
string and then you know there might be
some strength in being able to do this
but conceptually one way of looking at
it is instead of having two functions
which with the same image you could have
exponentially many functions with the
same image that you can build from the
two functions you know generically you
know as long as you can iterate these
these guys and then yeah I mean so I
guess the question could be is that sort
of thing useful at all beyond what
you're doing so that's an open question
yeah we tried to use it in various ways
we haven't I don't know what it's useful
for yet but maybe yeah okay so okay so
now that I told you about Raptor claw
free functions I need to link them back
to homomorphic encryption and it turns
out that that trapdoor Class C functions
are very useful in building this
encrypted sinon operation and to tell
you about that I'm going to start by
defining a specialized type of
encryption which where the encryption is
just a trap door across free function
pair so now I'm going to tell you how to
encrypt a bit using a trap door
pre-function parent and the purpose of
telling you about this encryption is
because what I'll tell you is that with
this specialized encryption so if this
encryption of the bit s is just a
chapter of coffee function pair then
this encrypted C not operation is very
easy all the server has to do is use the
trapdoor class free function pair to
create a uniform superposition over a
qua and he's essentially done and then
and the final step so I tell you I'll
tell you that it's easy with the TCF
encryption and in the final step I have
to link back to classical homomorphic
encryption schemes and show how we can
use similar techniques to do this
conversion with a classical homomorphic
encryption scheme so to start what does
it mean to encrypt a bit using a trap
door claw free function pair now to do
this I'll define a slightly different
TCF pair it's almost the same but
there's a bit of different notation so
the first thing I've done is I've split
up the domain now you have a single bit
and then you have the rest of the domain
which is some set arm think of it as bit
strings again and then you have the same
image Y now the first conditions are the
same it's injective the two functions
have the same image there's a trapdoor
and I've written the clause differently
now mu 0 and mu 1 are bits they come
from the first part of the domain R 0
and R 1 are longer strings and the claw
free property should still hold and the
final condition here which is what makes
it an encryption
there is an extra property for all claws
the first bit of the klom hides the bit
s so new 0 X or mu1 is equal to X and
this is why I'm referring it to it as an
encryption because now in each claw of
this TCF pair we are hiding the bit s so
this is just a different form of hiding
the bit s and now I'm going to show you
how this TCF encryption can be used for
the encrypted scene on operation so
remember the goal of the encrypted C not
operation the server is given the
encryption of s now in this case the
encryption of s is just as TCF pair s 0
and F 1 given this encryption of s the
server wants to conditionally apply the
C naught operation to an arbitrary two
qubit quantum state so this is our
arbitrary state and he's applying the C
naught to the power s which means if s
equals 0 is doing nothing if s equals 1
he's exhorting a in to the second
register and just for simplicity I'm
going to assume that B equals 0 and so
all we're doing is we're computing a dot
s in the second register now how do you
do this with a TCF pair so like I said
earlier all the server has to do is use
F 0 and F 1 to sample a random line and
entangle has state with the
corresponding clock so the clause here
looked like mu a ra where mu a is a
single bit this is done exactly as I
just showed you earlier he creates a
uniform the server creates a uniform
superposition over the domain applies a
function in superposition depending on
that bit a so that bit a tells him
whether to apply F 0 or F 1 he measures
the final register to get an image Y due
to the entanglement in the state the
resulting state will be a superposition
over the two pre images of Y now why is
this useful it's because of what I said
earlier new 0 X or mu 1 equals s so once
the server entangles his state with the
claw he has taken s and put it into his
quantum state of course it's hidden
because ok so first let me just so mu 0
X or mu 1 equals s and 1 that
I have this equality so just to break
this down I've rewritten that second
register and so first let's say when a
equals zero that second register is just
new zero exactly the same as the first
line and when a equals 1 the second
register is new 0x or S which is equal
to mu1 due to the fact that mu 0 XR mu 1
equals s so all I've done in the second
line is rewrite this state entangled
with the plot according to the Equality
that we have about the the claw hiding
the bit s and now in this second line if
you compare it to the very first line
where I wanted a dot s in the second
register it's almost there but there are
two things that are still messing up the
state
the first is mu 0 but mu 0 is just a
classical one-time pad so it's a pally X
operator the second thing that is
preventing the state from looking like I
want it to a system RA and Ra
essentially it can be turned into a
polyphase operator and the intuition is
that news there is not enough to fully
hide s because s is now stored in
superposition so RA is also needed to
kind of hide the information about s
which is in the superposition and Ra can
be turned into a polyphase operating so
what I said here is that these extra
parameters are serve the purpose of
hiding s and can be turned into the poly
encoding by the server so essentially
all he did was entangle the state with
the claw and went that the purpose that
served was to take the information about
s put it into his quantum state and the
only thing that's hiding it is this
power Li one-time pad so that was very
quick I'll go through it again and then
I'm gonna ask for questions now to recap
what I've said is that the encrypted si
not operation is easy for the quantum
server if the encryption of s is a
trapdoor query function in that case all
the server has to do to complete this
transformation is to use F 0 and F 1 2
hit entangle his input state with the
claw and just that procedure just
entangling the input state
the claw is enough to take information
about the bit/s put it in me a
superposition and it's only hidden by
new 0 and ra which serve as a POW a
one-time path and that's because new
zero is a classical one-time pad it's
just a bit shift and r0 and r1 can be
turned into policy writers now are there
any questions so I know that was fast
and we can go back if there is any
confusion about the previous site the
encryption of path is the pair of claw
is that is essentially description of
two functions values it's a public
description of two functions any more
questions
so this collapsing will be done as part
of the comma morphic iteration right so
some key to sample this to function
something yeah so this is one stuff of
the homomorphic computation this
encrypted sinon operation is part of the
homework of computation and to do the
encrypted sinon operation he uses the
TCF pair to entangle a state with a
clock so there are a few questions also
in the Q&A section do you like to look I
can just do it yeah so the first
question is why does the output equal to
a times s what's what's the output are
you talking money go back so I think I
think if I understand the question
correctly the question is why this value
that you get so you wanted your goal was
to actually get an encrypted a times s
value right you go from and the question
is why is this value that you actually
that you actually obtain is constitutes
you know an encryption of the value a
times it's why is this an encryption of
a taxes you mean so why is this this
final equation why is it an encryption
of a times s is that the question that's
my understanding of the question perhaps
yeah yeah okay so I think so it seems
like this person understands that this a
times s is in the state and you're
asking why it's an encryption and
remember the encryption that we're using
is the poly one-time pad so all I need
to argue is that this state on the third
line is the same as the one on the first
line but it's also a poly one-time pad
and the way to see that is that mu zero
is a bit flipped
it's a classical one time time so that's
the X probably one time pad and R 0 and
R 1 is a bit trickier but what how it
turns out is that if the server performs
a Hadamard transform on this R 0 R 1
register and he measures r0 and r1 is
converted into a phase and a phase is
just a paui one-time pad so mu 0 is an X
a bit shift and then R 0 and R 1 are
just the fades one-time pad so it is
those are still some who collapse to
like a beat so now they're like long
strings and then but some of this
transformation you collapse it to this
one time pad beat exactly yeah and the
one time pad will kind of be an inner
product of R 0 and R 1 with some other
string and that's achieved by performing
the Hadamard transform on the quantum
Fourier transform
there's also another question which is
how to how to generate encryption how do
you generate encryptions of U 0 R 0 and
R 1 okay so that can be done
classically with a homomorphic
computation because if the server has
access to the encrypted trapdoor of F 0
and F 1 then what the server can
homomorphic li compute is he can start
with y encrypt it and then using the
trap the encrypted trap door he can
compute the encryptions of MU 0 R 0 nu 1
R 1 and then he's done and remember all
the server needs to do is output the
one-time padded quantum state along with
the classically encrypted one-time pad
keys so as long as he can do this
computation homomorphic Li he's good
any other questions so are you going to
go over like I mean the final think I
mean I think you started to answer too
connected with fhe like this I mean
basically the questions that you answer
they were going to go over three till
and just the summary of what you
achieved right so there are different
ways to connect it to fhe I don't know
if you're asking about the question that
was just asked in terms of computing
these keys is that what you're asking
essentially because you hear what you
said it looks like you're saying here is
a particular encryption of s which is
not necessarily from a more feet and
here's how it helps you to do this in
node but now you have to connect it one
layer about this something which is
comorbid which I think I understand but
it might be helpful if you have slides
to just kind of put everything together
the next part of the talk so but just
about the question that was last asked
in this picture the server is about
putting the encryption of X and Z and
like I just said that's possible to
compute homomorphic Li as long as you
have the encrypted trapdoor of F 0
okay any more questions alright so now
I'm going to continue but before I
continue let me just say what I've done
so far and what remains to be done so I
started off by telling you that the
whole amorphic computation of quantum
circuit circuits boils down to the
server's ability to convert a classical
cipher text into a conditional C not
operation of just a quantum XOR
operation and I define something called
the encrypted C not operation which
formalizes this notion in which the
quantum server takes this input a
classically encrypted bit s an arbitrary
two qubit quantum state and he
conditionally applies the C naught to
the state's I and he outputs the one
time padded resulting state and what I
just told you is that this conversion is
easy for the server if the encryption of
s has this special form if the
encryption of s is just a trapdoor claw
free function pair then the server can
very easily perform this transformation
just by entangling his state with a
random claw so that's what's been done
so far but now the next step is to link
back to classical homomorphic encryption
schemes so if you remember in this in
this picture the reason that this bit is
encrypting is because the server had
these parallel classical and quantum
computations where he had these
homomorphic lien cryptid one-time pad
keys and he was updating them and he
eventually had to apply a quantum
operation dependent on these keys and
because of how this works because of the
fact that the quantum server has to
homomorphic Lee update the one-time pad
keys we really need this encryption to
be a classical homomorphic encryption
because otherwise the server won't be
able to update the one-time pad keys
like with the encryption that I just
showed you with this chapter claw free
encryption I have no idea what the
homomorphic properties of that are so in
order to complete this scheme I really
need to link this back I need to say
that if the server receives the
encrypted bit s and this encryption is a
classical homomorphic encryption scheme
he can still perform the
conversion and one way one particularly
simple way to do this is let's say the
server receives this encrypted bit s
under some classical home morphic
encryption scheme is it possible for him
to take this encryption and convert it
into a TCF pair so he just sees the
encryption of X and from that the server
should be able to compute public
descriptions of F 0 and F 1 which
constitute the TCF encryption of a bit s
and if he can do this if there are
classical homomorphic encryption schemes
which kind of allow him to convert
encryptions in this way then he's done
because what he does is he starts with
his classical homomorphic encryption
scheme encrypting the bit s he computes
F 0 and F 1 then he can very easily do
the encrypted C naught operation and
that's all he needs to do so that's the
question are there classical homomorphic
encryption schemes for which the server
can start with the encryption of a bit s
and produce this TCF encryption F 0 and
F 1 and this is now just a purely
classical question because we know what
we need to do it has nothing to do with
the quantum saying anymore and it turns
out that the I think maybe there's some
interest in like a bit more me to
clarify or repeat what exactly it means
to encrypt s that s is encrypted using a
claw free pair can you say again what
you mean by this by this term let me go
back to ok here's what it means if a bit
isn't ok this is a TCF encryption of a
bit s it's a pair of quarry functions F
0 and F 1 I've split up the domain so
the first part is a bit and these
properties are just saying that it's a
claw free function pair the function
pairs are injective they have the same
image there's a trapdoor it's hard to
find a clock and I've broken up the claw
so that museum and me1 are bits the
final property is what makes it an
encryption and what this says is that
for all claws the first bit of the claw
mu 0 and mu 1
hide the bit s and the XOR so mu 0 XR mu
1 equals s
do you think about this so it's sort of
a one-time encryption right so you're
you're giving me the cipher text which
is f 0 f 1 and in order to decrypt well
any way that allows you to find a claw
will actually allow you to serve decrypt
the cipher yes so what is a key change
is it a public encryption a symmetric
key encryption so there is a you know
encryption scheme so we are just like a
syntax you talked about encryption we'll
talk about key generation here right I
didn't talk about key generation I visit
the public key encryption oh you view it
as a public key encryption is a trapdoor
I think I don't think public key makes
sense because like I said it's kind of a
one-time use thing right okay yeah
that's yeah you're saying do do you
envision that there is a normal pair of
claw free permutations without the zero
one distinction and you implicitly
thinking of constructions that converts
a regular close repair g0 g1 take
something like that I'm not following
your question at all could you repeat it
well it's like your definition it's like
you know usually this would be some
distribution of fast so you're saying
there is a procedure right I mean it's
you just don't complete you told about
encryption you didn't talk I think
that's a confusion so do you think there
is a form of a permutation pair and you
skip the part help from normal for free
g0 g1 if you need f0 in a bun Oh F 0 or
there is no G 0 G 1 you already define X
0 in the bun but then you didn't tell
about you know what is it all will be -
are you saying even if it s you can
sample at 0 at 1 a business property
please like a syntax part missing here
like a connection well I mean this so
trapped our clog-free function pairs can
always be sampled from some set so sure
you could say that it's a symmetric
encryption scheme where he just samples
the key of a trapdoor claw free function
to give an S so you're saying given s
you're saying that is a generation
algorithm that takes a bit s and
a pair of zero and a one having this
property rights having these three
properties that you stated
sure yeah you can particular the
semantic security is part of the
definition it's not it's not something
that follows from the law freeness right
it does not follow from the cloth
rhiness okay it could be that he can
find a cloth that he can find museu a
new one but he can't find the cloth and
then he break the encryption so it does
not follow from puffiness puffiness is
necessary and clearly if it's not free
you break the encryption but the
semantic security is part of your
definition of yes clustering this is
necessary but not sufficient and the
reason that this isn't fully defined is
because this is kind of like a stepping
stone it's not so what I'll show next is
I'll just link classical homomorphic
encryption yes and this is never kind of
used on a standalone
got it yeah but do I mean actually
doesn't the semantic security follow
from these properties because if I if I
know is if I can recover s somehow then
I can just find a claw by setting like
getting some arbitrary mu zero and then
setting new one could be mu zero X or s
and then I found a claw and broke the
claw freeness right you didn't find a
claw because you didn't find R 0 and R 1
no sorry right you need to find to the
earth so that's why it's not obvious
oh it's also but my understanding maybe
I'm wrong it looks like for s equals 0
there is one third a function of 0 and a
1 when s equals was it is a completely
different pair of function so that was
my confusion it's not like that is like
one big step zero and the one because
once you fix it zero in the one it kind
of fixes s so some point seems like that
you know yeah I was also curious about
this function but it looks like it is
part of the definitions of semantic
security yeah
okay so I'll continue now to linking
this the classical homomorphic
encryption schemes so the question here
was whether there exists classical
homomorphic encryption schemes for which
the server can take his in front the
encryption of a bit s under that scheme
and convert it to a TCF encryption so he
can take his input the encryption of a
bit s and produce public descriptions of
the functions X 0 and F 1 for which each
claw hides the bit s and it turns out
that there are a classical homomorphic
encryption schemes for which this
conversion is possible and that's what
I'm going to show you next so what I'll
do now is I will start with the
encryption of s define the pair of
functions F 0 and F 1 and then I'll say
that if the classical homomorphic
encryption schemes satisfy certain
requirements then F 0 and F F 1 actually
constitute a TCF pair encryption and the
next step I can do is take all these
requirements and put them together and
once we formalize these requirements we
can say that if a classical homomorphic
encryption scheme satisfies these
requirements then the server can use
these schemes to convert to TCF
encryptions and then apply the encrypted
C naught operation and there therefore
the server can use these classical
homomorphic encryption schemes to
homomorphic Li evaluate quantum circuits
and I call classical homomorphic
encryption schemes which satisfy those
requirements quantum capable schemes and
those are just classical holistic
encryption schemes which can be used to
homomorphic we evaluate quantum circuits
and the final thing that I'll tell you
after I'm done with all of this is I'll
tell you that there does exist a quantum
capable classical homomorphic encryption
scheme scheme and this scheme can be
constructed by combining existing
schemes in literature so now I'll start
by producing s by defining F 0 and F 1
starting with the encryption of a bit s
and this is just a reminder of what I
want the TCF encryption to look like and
I'll need this reminder because what I'm
going to do now
is define f0 and f1 and then tell you
what the classical homomorphic
encryption scheme has to look like in
order to satisfy these requirements so
f0 is easy to define it's just the
encryption function so we're working
with the public key classical
homomorphic encryption scheme so there
is an encryption function which takes as
input a bit to be encrypted and some
randomness so mu 0 will be the bit to be
encrypted R 0 will be the randomness and
f 0 will just take his input both and
output a ciphertext
f1 is almost the same as f-zero but is
shifted by the homomorphic XOR of the
ciphertext encryption of s so this is
where we use the encryption of s to
define as 0 in f1
now so f1 it takes as input Mew 1 and R
1 it first applies F 0 so it computes
the ciphertext of the bit meet one with
randomness R 1 then it homomorphic the
XOR is the encryption of s 2 that
ciphertext to get the output of F 1 so
now I've defined these two functions F 0
and F 1 starting from the encryption of
s and these functions can be publicly
evaluated just given the encryption of s
and now the next thing I need to do is I
need to tell you that these two
functions F 0 and F 1 actually
constitute a trust or law free function
pair so our chapter across the
encryption of the business and before
that are there any questions about the
definition of this function at least I
have a question so do you still require
an encryption of the trapdoor starting
with an encryption of this beta test
along with this TCF pair F 0 F 1 which
chapter so I will so the trapdoor for
this cloth be fair well I haven't
defined that yet so I'm I'm starting
with an encryption of a bit s and then
I'm gonna create a TCF pair and that TCF
pair will have a trapdoor and the
quantum server will have to have access
to the encryption of that trapdoor in
order to do this key update yeah yeah so
so you still need this property right
you need the quantum server to have an
encryption of the trapdoor yes I always
need that property for that yes so this
is a particular you defining a
particular construction of TCF pair from
a comma morphic encryption and I guess
you later tell us what properties of
karthick encryptions you need but this
is a construction of TCR pair from some
kind of special kind of homomorphic
encryption is it there so far there's
nothing special about the home morphic
encryption scheme I started with an
arbitrary classical homework that
encryption scheme encrypting a bit X and
I'm saying from that I can define these
functions at 0 with f1 but now what I
need to do is say that actually f0 and
f1 constitute the TCF encryption and to
say that the classical homework that
encryption scheme will have to satisfy
certain properties in just an aside
I mean obviously this is what you need
for this construction but just as an
aside question if you forget about fhc
properties I mean this is like a
classical definition is encryption can
you build it out of curiosity I don't
know if it's interesting and you build
it from any lore not law three
permutations I mean what you know like
if you just concentrate to understand
their properties can we do that
contracting from any implementation what
do we know I don't I don't know and I
don't know if anyone who studied this I
don't I don't know if anyone else knows
you need to know other speaker ok yes ok
so I've defined these functions and now
I need to tell you that these functions
are ATC F encryption and to do that
let's just go through the properties so
let's start at the last property we need
all claws to hide the bit s now this is
very easily satisfied because of how
I've defined the functions so f1 is just
a shift of f0 by the homomorphic XOR of
the encryption of the bit s so just by
this definition it follows that if f0
and f1 map to the same point then new 0x
or mu 1 equals s that's follows from the
definition now this also implies the
claw free property because if it were
possible to find a claw using this
public description of the functions then
the server could just break the initial
encryption of the bit ESTs so those two
properties are straightforward the next
one is a trapdoor property and this is
the first time I'm going to have to put
a constraint on the classical
homomorphic encryption scheme and what I
will need is that the classical
homomorphic encryption scheme must have
a trapdoor which allows for randomness
recovery from ciphertext because
eventually what we want is that when we
look at an image why we're able to
recover the pre image which is new 0 R 0
or mu 1 R 1 and so looking at a cipher
text Y we have to be able to recover the
randomness which was used to create the
cipher text and this is a condition on
classical homomorphic encryption schemes
because there are schemes for which this
requirement does not
so this is a first constraint the
classical homomorphic encryption scheme
must have a trapdoor which allows for
randomness recovery and this requirement
also implies that F 0 and F 1 are
injected the final constraint which is
the hardest to satisfy is that the
function pairs F 0 and F 1 have to have
the same image now this is tricky
because given how I define the functions
the images won't overlap perfectly
because F 1 is f 0 shifted by the
homomorphic XOR so this is hard to
satisfy and what I'm going to do is I'm
going to weaken this condition of having
the images overlap perfectly and I'll
weaken it just so that it it's
sufficient for what I need in my setting
so the weekend requirement says that
instead of the images overlapping
perfectly there exists a distribution
over the domain of F 0 and F 1 such that
the resulting distributions over the
images are statistically closed
equivalent an equivalent way of stating
this is that there exists a distribution
over ciphertext which doesn't change
much if it is shifted by the homomorphic
XOR of the encryption of this bit s and
just to tell you why this is what I need
in my setting remember why we need the
same image requirement we need the fact
that when the quantum computer applies
this function in superposition and he
measures the image then the remaining
state will collapse to these two pre
images to this claw another way of doing
that with the quantum machine is he
doesn't have to create a uniform
superposition over the domain he can
create a superposition according to some
distribution and then measure Y and as
long as for that distribution the image
wise still has two pre images then we're
okay so that's what this requirement is
formalizing it's saying we don't need
the same images we just need a
distribution for which the resulting
distribution over images is
statistically closed
so this is a different it's a weaker
requirement it's enough for a quantum
homomorphic encryption and now what I
need to tell you is what a classical
homomorphic encryption scheme has to
look like in order to satisfy this we
can require and before that are there
any questions just on this requirement
or on any of their comments I've listed
so far
you
you
okay so now I need to tell you what a
classical homomorphic encryption scheme
needs to look like in order for this
requirement to hold and I'm going to
start with a very simplistic picture of
what of what encryption schemes might
look like so let's imagine that the
encryption of a bit zero is just a
random element sample from some group h
some subgroup h perturbed by some small
amount of noise Epsilon so that's the
encryption of a zero and the encryption
of one is almost the same except instead
of sampling from H you would sample from
some cosine of H so this is just a very
simple form of what encryptions look
like and I'm using this form because I
want to try to describe to you what a
classical homomorphic encryption scheme
could look like in order to satisfy the
surprise so let's say the first thing
that I want from the scheme is that
throughout the computation the
ciphertext form has this nice form like
encryptions of zero are samples from the
subgroup and perturbed by some amount of
noise encryptions of one or similar and
as you compute on the ciphertext this
form doesn't change the noise might
change and grow in different ways but
the rough form of just having something
from this subgroup each perturbed by
noise remains the same so this is
something that I'll call the ciphertext
form requirement and the next thing that
I would like is that the homomorphic XOR
operation is natural in the sense that
the homomorphic XOR is just adding
ciphertext now if these two requirements
hold then it's quite easy to construct
distributions which satisfy this
requirement and to see that let's assume
that the noise of this ciphertext the
encryption of s is Epsilon then all we
need to do is choose an initial
distribution over noise let's say some
Gaussian distribution over noise where
the width of the Gaussian is
sufficiently larger than Epsilon now if
that holds so we look at our initial
distribution over ciphertext if we take
this distribution and shift it by the
encryption of s it will barely change
because the width of it was large enough
to essentially erase the noise of s
which is epsilon and this technique is
well known to cryptographers and it's
called noise sweating and it's used in
circuit privacy and that's exactly what
I'm using here so I'm just using these
properties to say that the distribution
is easy to define because we can just
define a distribution which doesn't
change much when it is shifted by the
encryption of
so what I've done here is I've weakened
the distribution requirement I've week
in the same image requirement to say
that all we need are distributions which
are statistically close then I said that
this requirement is easy to satisfy if
the homomorphic encryption scheme has
some nice properties so if the cipher
text form remains roughly the same
throughout the computation and if the
XOR operation is just addition of
ciphertext then these things are easy to
satisfy
and now the next thing I need to tell
you is are these easy to satisfy are
their classical homomorphic encryption
schemes which satisfy these requirements
and before that are there any questions
on just this side or what what these
what this requirement means
so my next problem is that I needed
these two requirements
I needed a cipher text form to stay
roughly the same throughout the
computation and I needed the X or the
homomorphic XOR to just be the addition
of ciphertext and from what I know no
one schemes don't satisfy both of these
requirements at the same time so I did
have to change one thing slightly and
what I changed was that I used two
schemes one which satisfied the form
requirement and one would satisfy the X
or Akane and when I did was that the
quantum server can use a scheme which
satisfies the form requirement
throughout his classical homomorphic
computation but whenever he needs to do
an encrypted Sina operation whenever he
needs to take one of his ciphertext and
convert them to a quantum operation then
he can take his homomorphic ciphertext
convert it into an alternate scheme
which satisfies only the XOR requirement
and then use this converted ciphertext
to run the encrypted cena operation and
so now so far i've told you all of the
requirements that I need from the
classical homomorphic encryption scheme
in order to allow this conversion from a
ciphertext to a TCF pair and these
requirements can be pretty easily
formalized define something called
quantum capable classical homomorphic
encryption schemes these are homomorphic
encryption schemes for which the server
can start with the encryption of a bit
ESTs convert it to a TCF encryption and
then use that TCF encryption to apply
the encrypted c not operation and so
these schemes allow for homomorphic
evaluation of quantum circuits and that
the final thing that I need to do is
tell you that there does exist a quantum
capable classical homomorphic encryption
scheme which I can construct by
combining existing schemes and
literature and I'll tell you that
briefly and it'll be technical but
hopefully if it'll just be for the
experts to follow and if you don't
follow don't worry about it but before
that are there any questions so far yes
so there's a question from the audience
on so the question is why doesn't any
fhu which circuit privacy sufficient for
what you need because circuit privacy it
doesn't necessarily
thoroughly imply this distribution
requirement so I am using circuit one
circuit privacy technique to satisfy
this but to me it's not clear that
circuit privacy if you just take the
definition would imply that you'd get
these overlapping distributions is it a
requirement of the distribution Soren
generating
under these distributions yeah so the
requirement is that you have a
distribution for which the images are
statistically closed and on top of that
you have to be able to create a secret
position over the distribution so you're
right that that is actually a big
constraint because I from what I know
there are some circuit privacy
techniques which are kind of hard to
undo so it would be hard to create a
distribution create a superposition over
this so is that the person who asked the
question is satisfied so nice flooding
is one way to get circuit privacy right
I mean there are there are a few other
ways to do it
and you know some some even nice and
algebraic actually you know and the
reason these guys don't work is because
either they work or if they don't work
it's because of this superposition
requirement yes yes and Janica would
know more about that because in his
paper you do this things weaker and it's
G inverse multiplied by G inverse type
yeah you need to be careful about sir
generating the right superposition okay
I got it
okay any more questions on the
requirements of form
okay and now just to finish up for those
of you who are very familiar with
existing classical homomorphic
encryption schemes I just wanted to tell
you what schemes I'll be using and just
to remind you I need a scheme for which
the ciphertext forum stays roughly the
same the whole time meaning the main
structure is the same but maybe the
noise is changing and then I also need a
scheme for which it is easy to convert
from the original scheme and the XOR
operation is natural so let me just tell
you briefly what these schemes are so
the scheme that I'll use for the
ciphertext form requirement is the gen
trace the high-water scheme from 2013
and just to remind you this scheme uses
standard lwe encryption so it uses a rag
of encryption but it takes these vector
ciphertext and expands them into
matrices and the nice thing is that
these ciphertext a roughly the same
throughout the computation only the
noise changes but remember that I need
randomness recovery for the trapdoor and
the gfw scheme does not have randomness
recovery because the reg of scheme
doesn't have randomness recovery luckily
there's an easy solution to this instead
of using reggae use the dual of rekha
which is the gentry peak here at my
cousin oven scheme and so what I can do
is use the same structure of DSW 13
which is expanding these vector
ciphertext into matrices but instead of
using the Reg of ciphertext I'll use the
GPD ciphertext and now we have a scheme
which satisfies the suffice the vertex
form requirement and has randomness
recovery it has a trapdoor for RIM and
the final thing I need is I need a
scheme so the problem with this is that
the XOR operation isn't natural the
natural operation for this scheme is the
NAND gate to build the XOR gate I'd have
to use a NAND gate so the XOR operation
wouldn't just be adding ciphertext so to
take care of that issue what we can do
is whenever the server needs to apply
the encrypted C naught operation so he
needs to do this XOR he just takes his g
SW ciphertext and he converts it back to
a gpv ciphertext and to do that all he
has to do is pick one column of his g SW
ciphertext now that resulting ciphertext
has a very nice XOR operation
in the GPB scheme the XOR operation is
just addition of ciphered so this is all
I just wanted to briefly say what
schemes I use and how I use them so all
I'm doing is I'm combining the GSW
scheme and the GPD scheme to get all the
requirements that I need now let me just
wrap up the talk so I started by telling
you that quantum homomorphic encryption
boils down to the ability of the server
to convert a classically encrypted bit
into a quantum operation and I called
this the encrypted C not operation then
I told you that this encrypted C not
operation is quite easy for a special
type of encryption which which I called
a trapdoor claw free encryption in this
encryption the encryption of a bit s is
just a tractor a claw free function pair
for which each claw hides the bits and
given this type of encryption all the
server needs to do to perform this
encrypted sinon operation is entangle
his state with the call then I needed to
link this back to classical morphic
encryption schemes I needed to say that
there are classical homomorphic
encryption schemes for which the server
can start with the encryption of a bit s
and convert it to a TCF pair which hides
the bit X and it turns out that there
are requirements which we can state for
a classical homomorphic encryption
scheme for which if these requirements
hold then the classical homomorphic
encryption scheme allows this conversion
to a TCF pair
I called such schemes quantum capable
and these schemes allow homomorphic
evaluation of quantum sir
finally I said that there are existing
schemes and literature which can be
combined to form a quantum capable
scheme and all these schemes depend on
the security of learning with errors and
the presence of quantum computers so
what this is saying is that a quantum
capable classical homomorphic encryption
scheme can be constructed under the
computational assumption of learning
with errors and if we put all that
together what is saying is that blind
delegation of quantum computations by a
classical client is possible under the
assumption that learning with errors is
quantum secure that's all I have for my
talk
thanks for listening thank you any more
questions
you
there are a lot of questions during the
talk yes certainly I have one parting
question which is you know why do you
need
GSW here it wasn't completely clear to
me why you know why do you stubble you
if this could have been a
misunderstanding in my part I think
we've talked about this before I thought
I needed it because I thought in the
other schemes the cipher texts get
Messier as you continue with the
homomorphic computation and and I
thought that for GSW the ciphertext stay
the same so it could be that my
understanding although other schemes was
not good enough and then actually those
ciphertext have a nice form throughout
the computation and you can use that so
they do have a nice form through the
computation it's just that something you
know you can think about anamorphic
evaluation is sort of two steps one
makes the ciphertext Messier and well
then you quickly bring it back
tu-tu-tu-tu-tu-tu a nice form and then
you keep continuing that sort of yeah
you think so yeah maybe you can take it
offline you know uh yeah I think you
brought this up earlier and I yeah I
think we agreed that it sounded good
I don't know I I think mica might know
more about this but I mean you go why
doesn't BB work and I I don't I don't
think that the reason that GSW is used
is because that's the only solution that
works it's just because this is a
solution don't work and GSW is sort of
the canonical scheme that you try in a
situation I think in willows paper
there's actually just a list of
requirements right so you can just try
to sort of go over them and see if other
schemes are going to have this and I
don't see why not
so I don't see like they thought I did
it they do I didn't we do need the
randomized recovery that's important
sure sure sure absolutely but random is
recovery in the trapdoor is usually is
usually okay yeah cuz you can always
just convert to the dual right yeah for
example yeah but anyway I'll take this
off wouldn't dig this up like what
let's just a clarification question how
many this encryption of a static line
actually need to sent to the server is
it as big as a circuit or not oh it
depends it's the same as classical so if
you assume levelled if you want level
fully homomorphic encryption then it's
gonna correspond to the depth of the
quantum circuit and if you want if
you're willing to assume circular
security and it has nothing to do with
the size IC and everything you said you
focus on the fact that there is a
classical client if if the client is
also content so every since your work
sorry the client if I wanna do it I
quantum input and output yes it's all
exactly the same okay thanks I have
another question this is probably a
quantum W but you said at the beginning
of the talk that the output of the C not
on an encryption of s should be
encrypted because otherwise the server
would write CPA security yeah of s but
this is only if the server performs a
measurement or if there's some
imaginable way that this is there
something one could imagine the server
not being allowed to measure and also
not end up with an encryption of this
encryption of s-sorry I
I thought you didn't mean the encryption
of s but you were talking about the
encryption
so no it's not because what I I need the
encrypted Xenon operation to hold for an
arbitrary to Cuba quantum state and if
the output is not encrypted then it just
it can't hold for an arbitrary two qubit
quantum states because the server yes
exactly and that has nothing to do with
measuring or not because what he could
do is he could set his state so it's a
standard base of state it's not even in
superposition and so he doesn't even
have to like yeah so uh yeah yeah I
don't think there's any way that you
could do it if it's not encrypted you
would just violate security okay thank
you yeah another question
from the Q&A panel so the question is
why you need to put white around with
the encryption is actually the input to
the claw free function and not some
other you know what why is there this
connection between the randomness is the
encryption and input of the of the claw
free function and you don't use some
other value as an input for the for the
claw free function what other around
you're gonna use I was just yeah I just
picked the most or maybe maybe you want
you maybe is there a reason to sort of
think that this would be the natural
thing the natural thing to use the the
RAM knows the encryption to me it seemed
natural because I was just defining f0
and f1 to be the encryption functions
and what is I mean your public
encryption function it takes as input a
bit and some randomness there could be
many other ways of doing this I'm not
saying that other ways are bad to me it
was just the first thing that came to
mind any other questions
all right let's thank Romila again thank
you very much